what makes this question difficult well
because it doesn't fit into this you
can't even start this until you've got
the right hand side okay so if I gave if
you got presented goodness where would
you go okay I sort of gave you a clue I
said well we have to you have to work
out what this pattern is going to be and
then you can start to establish the
proof based on our principle of
mathematic reductions right so how do
you find out what might it be well you
use cipher use our good old friend guess
and check know um guess and check it's
not the greatest tool in the world but
it will do enough to help us get a
patent okay that's all we're after
okay so for starters rather than having
question marks over here I need to call
this thing on the right something give
it a name so that I actually have
statement right so since this is our
Mystery's it's not the napier GP but
it's a serious number list i will call
it s of him series the sum of the first
n terms because that's how many I have
over here all right now I've got some
names and some labels I can start to
talk about some conjecture okay so I'm
gonna draw up the table for myself I'm
gonna have values of n over here and
then I'll have values for the whole
series on the other side so let's try
some table
okay now how many number this is sorry
how many values for M do you think I
should test three four five enough till
you see a pattern okay I think I got two
I think I got two four and I started
getting suspicious and then I need five
just to really okay so that's how many
I'm gonna do with you let's do one okay
how many times am I gonna have if n is
equal to one I'm gonna have one term
right because this series has interns in
that means just the first one okay so
it's one on two factorial which is just
a half okay if you're not if you're not
watching this by the way that's fine but
everyone else all right that was easy
enough let's do the next one - okay so
I'm gonna have the first two terms now
so 1 on 2 factorial plus 2 on 3
factorial 1/2 plus now 3 man Torrio is 3
times 2 times 1 C right
so whenever 2 & 6 I'll have a third okay
what's 1/2 is a bit 5/6 right
3 sixths and two seats so okay nothing's
jumping out of it yet let's keep going
number three now rather than because
this is series this is a nice handy
trick right rather than work out of the
first three terms from scratch right
when N equals 3 I can take the first two
terms and just add the next one
and I already know what the first two
terms are right so I'll just save myself
a bit of work this is going to be the
previous one right when n is equal to 2
plus the third term ok does that make
sense so another way I could say this
maybe is this is s to write plus term 3
that's why you end up with s 3 does that
make sense
ok anyway I was in a cycle all right
what's the C equal to 5 over 6 plus
what's four factorial now I don't have
to work out all of what 4 factorial is
because I know I can get rid of the 3
right so I guess that's going to be 1
over 4 times mr 3 times 2 times 1
okay five seats +180 yeah okay I'll need
to comment denominator here I'll save
you some time 23 no bar
all right still nothing's really jumping
out of me then why notice there's this
sum these are always one less mmm it's
kind of weird let's see if we can make a
consistent patterns so for I'll take the
first three terms and I'll add the next
one which is 4 on 5 factorial
now 4 factorial was 24 if I had included
the 3 so 5 factorial would be five on
the 24
just hundred 20 so I'm gonna have 4
yeah yeah and I'm actually gonna have to
come back to what 20 together okay so
let's see here so far I have got I think
something consistent right at the very
least I've got a fraction and what's the
fraction made up of it's some number and
on the top it's the number minus one now
the question is what's the number
if you I did I did one more so be sure
okay but if you've been using a
calculator to working it to work out
your own your bigger numbers like 5
factorial you might already recognize
what the number is right when I get a 5
I'm gonna go 119 or 120 plus five one
six factorial which is five on 720 which
is equal to like I remember what secrets
oh yeah okay so good thing is I've got
my X and X minus 1 pattern okay now
let's have a look at these denominators
because that's the important number it
seems to 6 24 or 27 2010 hoc factorials
I do a calculator I can you recognize it
720 is a success story all right I just
got it there and 120 is 5 factorial and
there's 4 factorial that's kind of
obviously okay sir
what conjecture I think that's enough
isn't it what conjecture would you make
I think we want to say that Esav and
that Sun right on the denominator we've
got something factorial what's to
something it's always one more than now
value for M right so if it's one more
that's M plus one right and then you
take a factorial the whole thing what do
you have on the top that
okay now as we go through this I can now
starts actually test it out right and
prove it okay so let's test it for see
if our formula falls out for our first
allowable value okay sir
hopefully the numbers are pretty easy
let's have a go left hand side that's
equal to right hand side now it's the
moment of truth because this is the part
that we came up with right what are you
going on the top you've got one plus one
factorial minus one on one plus one okay
two factorial minus one on the street
factorial success I'm not going crazy
okay
so at least I proved it for the first
allowable value now what I do t a assume
okay just do a straight substitution for
yourself
all the way up to Kane I'm assuming is
yes
oops that's it okay so now what do I
have to prove I can fit it over here now
the reason why I'm going all the way
through and showing you the working is
because maybe thinking in factorials
that murdered the king is gone out of
your mind feel like you're eight maybe
so you've got to get yourself back in
the gears so you can factorize and get
everything simplify the way it needs to
be okay so for k plus one I'm gonna have
all of these first terms up again I'm
going to include that second last term
this one because it'll make my
substitution from the assumption easier
okay so I'll have K or k plus one
factorial here what's the last term of
this series it will be k plus all other
topics and the cameras leave it alone
okay so that's equal to
okay
so stage your step because this is a
series from practicing those before you
know when you've got a serious it's
usually easiest to start on the left
hand side because you've got all these
terms that you can sub out with your
assumption right so let's see left hand
side again just to save a bit of space
in your time I'm gonna skip a line I'm
gonna put the Assumption right in here
okay and it's sort of it actually is so
obvious right I've written it
deliberately that way there's my
assumption right or the left hand side
of the assumption anyway so I'm gonna
substitute in this
if by assumption by the way I've been
walking around here with your people
dancers when they've been asking for
help and that kind of thing
people keep forgetting to put this year
it's vital okay it's really crucial if
you don't have it it demonstrates you
sort of just doing this - so you're not
remembering this is a crucial step right
in fact this is the step that makes it
induction okay so don't forget to put
that in now all I have to do is get
these on a common denominator but again
if you're thinking in factorials how you
do that the difference in this amiss is
okay plus two right that's the next step
along so if this was say if K was say 10
okay this is the 11 factorial now be 12
factorial so degree from one of the
other I've got to multiply by that last
term okay okay that's right K plus 2 so
there we go
a plus 2 now when I multiply whoops
that's wrong not factorial I just needed
to the K + 2 when I multiply the
denominator by K plus 2 it turns into k
plus 2 factorial okay so by that logic I
can put them all on a single denominator
okay again here the same thing happens
right that k plus 2 in that Kapus 1
factorial combined together right and
there will be just K plus 2 factorial
okay
then I've got minus 1 Lots this so minus
k plus 2 plus K plus 1 okay I'm almost
there you can see the you guys I'm just
gonna cancel out with each other
case cancel that minus 2 plus 1 becomes
minus 1 and we are home and host ok so
it's equal to the right hand side and
therefore you can make your explanation
by the principle of mathematical
induction it's true for N equals 1 2 3
and so on